how are you feeling about being evicted
now that you know it's been a few hours
are you feeling fine about it how are
you feeling about it
well i think i understand the game and
the consequences of playing the game and
that's just one of the consequences
that's come along
if you don't win oh
i
did the best i could and i guess it was
just my time
i got you
um you know
towards the end we definitely saw you
sort of
uh formulating or wanting to form a plan
to
you know get out todrick why
specifically were you wanting to
uh target him to get him out of the
house
well because he had the strongest
alliance to um
you know to mesha who was um
yeah
who was strong competition i thought was
the strongest competition um
from the first day and she showed us
that with her winning the first hoh
then you know it was it was kind of
weird because he was over here and one
day and up there the next day it was
started to become easy to read
um
you know his movements and
and how he was playing a game
it's kind of easy to see see past it
why why him over misha i guess is more
of my my question
well him what why did you want to get
him out more than misha because you were
talking about like their alliance is
strong and like obviously he's attached
to a strong player why him
over misha
well no other reason for him
was being a follower of who i thought
was the strongest player
i got you
um
nothing leader like was about that
and i can i respect people more i can
lead the pack and be transparent
on what they want but you know what they
want to do to get there
um
i never kind of
engage on
his movement
i got you um you know people
all the time big brother talk about
wanting to play like an honest game you
know very open game i will say you
legitimately did you played a very
honest game you were very honest with
people from the get-go i mean you were
very honest about how much you knew
about the game and then you even told
you know in front of misha and todrick
that you wanted to get misha uh you're
trying to tell todd to get misha out so
um you know did you have any regrets
about being so honest about how you were
feeling in the game and how you were uh
sort of wanting to play the game
no
because um
here we are
the game is over and of course i'm gonna
spend
more time away from the game than i am
in the game
it's just like being a basketball player
you
get to a point where you realize there's
going to be a time where
your time away from the game is going to
surpass your time in the game you know
even somebody like lebron james
who's you know been playing 18 years
since the age of 19 in the nba
i'm pretty sure he plans to live a long
life
so his time away from the game he's
gonna you know it's gonna overlaps his
time in the game
and i wanted to be a wave i wanted to be
remembered as the guy you know away from
the game i can just chill with anybody
get along with anybody go out to dinner
with anybody
and you know and with that we will have
in common not just being celebrity or
in the celebrity big brother house
um you know
i don't know if you've had to
you've been online yet but you have a
lot of fan love you know a lot of fans
who are uh
really appreciated you in this game what
did that mean to you if you've seen it
yet and uh are you surprised by that
no i haven't i haven't seen it yet i
haven't even looked or paid attention to
it
um
you know but you know that's what it's
all about really
with me
um
um
you know i don't do things to make
others happy i do them to um
to make my grandmother proud
and so i know for that the way i played
the game she would be proud
um you know
again you kept it no secret um that you
weren't fully aware of some of the rules
and stuff of big brother
but you still made it
really far i mean
uh do you wish you had
known more going into the game now um
i wish my attention span was probably a
little better
when being told the rules of some of the
competition
uh
of some of the competitions i wish i
would have paid attention a little bit
more i think i would have finished
stronger
but then again
i played the role that i wanted to play
because i wouldn't want to win h0h and
didn't have the responsibility of you
know putting two people on the block
you know so yeah it kind of worked out
um
well for me and as far as my mental
health is concerned
you know at the end of the day i felt
like it worked out well for me
um one of the relationships i really
liked seeing on the show was you and
todd bridges um you know you you talked
about how
um his you know sobriety so important to
you and how you respect him i mean what
is it about todd that connects like you
connect with so much um i think we
probably you know walk down the same
road
um and
in a period of our life
making the wrong decisions
that you know hurt us and you know hurt
our family and our loved ones and
now just trying to do the things to
correct that and
you know todd was going over me
going
over with me some things that i can you
know do to feel better about myself and
uh he's gonna be my sober coach now
you know i think that's one of the
reasons why i met that young man in in
his house i think we can learn from each
other
he's from the west coast i'm from the
east coast
i think we can learn a lot i can learn a
lot from him
um something else people loved about you
on the show is how open you were you
were so open about mistakes you've made
in the past um you know even the stuff
with cody was so beautiful the way you
talked about him and then obviously
you're
talking about chloe um why did you want
to be so open why did you want to
discuss things like that so openly on
you know television like that
well you want me to be totally honest
with you
a lot of the things in the diary room i
i didn't even think it was for tv
um
i thought it was uh just for the the
station to keep
but i would have answered everything the
same
um
you know those two people are you know
put in my life for a reason i learned a
lot
from both of those relationships
and um
you know at this point in my life what
i'm trying to do is just you know be the
best of them all
and
actually you know learn from my mistakes
who knows it might help somebody else
deal with something
or deal with the relationship or
if they put in a situation like that you
know how to handle themselves correctly
and i learned a lot you know from kobe
um i dreamt him about four or five times
in that house
uh i know it had to be a reason because
there were some days where i was you
know emotionally weak
and just his spirit you know kind of
kept me going